why are we not doing the live stream
right now we've got live stream energy i
can't wait for you guys to know my
surprise it's gonna be so good you're
gonna [ __ ] die i'm scared we are so
hyper we actually are doing this promo
right now when we were supposed to be
shooting the marshmallows we're doing a
live stream right now we have all this
energy livestream energy and helium got
covered like what a loser gets covered
i don't think it's coming anymore the
last of the kovitz is this how she's
quitting our show wednesday april 13th 6
p.m pacific time get your tickets at
momenthouse.com
i have a surprise you have no idea what
it's going to be
do not miss it i will tell you something
i have a surprise that you guys are
screaming about i can't even i'm so
excited
annie and i are stand up freaking
comedians we are doing and by the way i
went up after esther the other day and
she was so funny we are both chris we're
both crushing it we're so funny we're
taking the audience fun on stage so much
fun you guys come see us april 15th and
16th i'm coming to austin texas the
shows are almost sold out get your
tickets and then i'm coming to brooklyn
at the bellhouse april 22nd and then dc
april 24th get your tickets and then in
may i'm coming to minneapolis
chicago
speed it up
i got some dates too sorry i'm high
estradis.com this was an epic episode
guys esther was high i will be in san
francisco the same week year wherever
you said you're going to be april 15th
and 16th i'll be in syracuse new york
april 22nd through 23rd san jose
california
may 6th and 7th dania beach florida may
12-14 burbank flappers comedy club june
18th if she's in town maybe i'll get her
to come austin texas cap city in august
tempe arizona i'm going to be at a
casino september 30th you can go to
annieletterman.com
shows to see all the dates it's been
epic go to our websites estronize.com
andyletterman.com
[Music]
are you high [ __ ]
how did you know oh my god do you know
that she just started getting high okay
why didn't you tell me exciting why
didn't you tell me to smoke weed no no
it's not like that i told you a little
bit of an edible earlier today i thought
it would because today we usually record
in the morning
it comes look at that little smile on
this little stoner i just
this is an accident i haven't seen in a
while and you have a wonderful just
general demeanor
but when i when i saw you today you
you had
just a little bit more energy excitement
yeah yeah and i was like yeah you
weren't just a potato that's the
difference you're a hot potato but that
i'm like that now not high like i'm just
i think it's like post covet i'm just
like excited about meeting people yeah
excited to be in the world
um more excited have you ever tried
micro dosing
the mushroom no should i i'm trying to
get around ketamine
i can't speak to that but here's the
thing mushrooms are like send you
because you will like mushrooms and do
them because they they help you like
through stuff why aren't you micro
dosing them all the time then i was
micro dosing it actually helped me with
my cluster headaches that was one of the
only like yours do you have tattoos you
know
i got like twenty three oh really okay
but did you wait oh because you waited
right you wanted to have no tattoos and
then you got one and then you went crazy
i always knew that i wanted to do what i
did which was get tattoos for every
member of my family that told the story
and so
that talk [ __ ] on you you're like every
member that told a family member they
told a story about me and got a [ __ ]
tattoo
yeah no mine's mine's with love yes
everyone tells a story i said that to
this guy at the apple store yesterday he
had this tattoo and i was like what's
your tattoo and he goes it's my aunt
passed away and i was like oh
like sorry you know but i was like
that's the only [ __ ] i would get would
be like family tattoos so that's
interesting you just said that well okay
so i feel like people get mad at us and
we don't introduce formally so nick vial
is here and i think the most important
thing about you which your reaction to
dare only confirmed it is you're a good
midwestern guy like you're a good person
and i have proof but just so people if
they don't know she says we have proof
we know it's proof if they don't know
you you're on the bachelor
you were on the bachelorette and the
bachelorette was the bachelorette i did
it all you were the bachelor and
you have a great podcast where you give
amazing dating advice thank you and you
might be working on a book are we the
book's done okay
but people know about it i i announced
the cover a couple weeks ago it doesn't
come out until october i don't know how
those things work it felt like
like you want me to announce it now yeah
um
i guess other people announce it like a
couple months before it comes out it
doesn't come out till october gotcha uh
so it's available for murder but yeah my
favorite thing about people also search
for don't text your ex happy birthday
it's the title of the book you used to
like that book that was a fun one tell
me what you think of the title i think
that's really cute don't text your ex do
you care what i think or just esther oh
yeah i'm sorry no that's okay i'm here
but it's fine i'm a fan esther's a fan
girl i'm just a regular it's not
flirtatious
no him because he was like hey um
okay here's my proof that you're a good
person
because on tick tock i always see clips
from your podcast where you're actually
being honest with women
about like dating advice that might hurt
their feelings yeah like
that makes me a good guy you're not like
gatekeeping and keeping women delusional
like we need to hear what like an honest
point of view from a guy and i don't
know anyone else that's doing that we're
a helpful lie you know like we're just
like
you know there's he's not good enough
for you no that's what it is he knows
you're too good for him you got to move
on yeah i honestly like
my book is very much like like my tick
tock
in terms of like the content and i i
wrote it um
like i honestly believe like i
i don't feel like i'm the guy who's like
talking to women
to tell them what to do or how to do
things like i haven't a male audience
too it's mostly predominantly women
but like i don't think that anything i
talk about is like gender specific it's
really just about
controlling what you can control
regardless of your gender or your sexual
orientation i'm glad you're not gender
specific with us
esther isn't either
but like we're not sure whoever you love
or whoever you are it's just like most
of like
everything i've talked about and that's
why i say that is because
uh i talk from someone who like just
i learned the hard way in my own life
and my like dating life and like when i
was in my twenties and i had a lot of
heartbreak and and it was like we
actually it wasn't like it wasn't even
on the show but it comes from a place of
like i wasted a lot of my own energy
uh worrying about things i couldn't
worry or like i was kind of a victim of
my own ego and thinking you know and
kind of chasing people that i shouldn't
be chasing or trying to validate myself
of things that didn't matter and it's
really just a lot about that so i do try
to give people like an honest assessment
if they ask me a question about their
situation but it's not really about like
i'm definitely not the guy who's like
guys like it when you do x y or z or and
things like that it's so smart it's just
more about being honest with yourself
about like your situation and like i did
this like
recently i don't know if you saw tic toc
the uh doesn't freaking matter he's not
your boyfriend yeah
that that was more specific to like
obviously
you know women who who date men but
most of it is just like
stop we all lie to ourselves
more than anyone lies to anyone else
and we negotiate with ourselves more
than anyone else negotiates with us and
if we can just stop doing that we make
life a little bit easier on ourselves
it's my general like
you know
like a lot of people who
who like or see my advice or like the
people who read read the book it's like
oh it's like the modern he's just not
into you
book and i guess to some degree it is
but in that book
there's very much like the overall theme
is
you're not the exception to the rule
you're like you're the rule right
and i think that's not really helpful
advice because
we all want to believe that we're the
exception to rule like we should like i
wouldn't be sitting where i am today if
i didn't take risks like if i
only did things based off of like well i
guess i'm not the exceptional rule i'll
just be mr ordinary and i won't like
take risks that might not work out i
wouldn't be
sitting here
and i just tell people like if you're
gonna if you're gonna take risks if
you're gonna move in with your partner
you're gonna start ahead of time
or start a podcast or whatever just
admit to yourself and acknowledge that
you are taking a risk that it's
you know if you're going to chase some
guy or some girl that you're into who's
not like just acknowledge that like
there might be some hurdles here you
know if you're gonna try to
have a long-distance relationship like
don't pretend it's the same as dating
someone across the street if you're
gonna date someone who's a little older
or younger than you don't pretend that
there aren't the same and like that's
what people do esther when you're
outside your ex-boyfriend's house across
the street do you consider that living
across the street from him
i was in a parked car
and it was during you know how people
have like regular like they have
destination weddings and then they have
like a local wedding for like the local
friends back at home it was that wedding
it wasn't his main wedding and i was
outside
and just standing there with him
with a boot box on top of your head like
say anything
um
but
i load a cell phone instead of a
carlos was just at in skokie in my
hometown with me and
were you there yeah were you her day to
the wedding
no i was there the weekend before i was
not at the wedding was she with you
what do you mean for a second i was like
what did you go scout no but every time
i go
every time i go home i like to drive
past my ex's house and carlos was there
when i asked my mom you really do that
yeah why memories
nostalgia memory girl
do you
is that that crazy he says don't even
read them happy birthday so yes
that's true i'm with you on that i feel
like i have like oh totally by the way
listen if who's in your seat usually if
you're like let's call our exes like
every day i'm like if you're uh
i'm a nostalgic person so i don't mind
like
if you go back to your hometown and
check out a place that used to bring you
like memories like i have nothing but
like
happy memories about all my exes who
like at times i
cried over but like it's been so long
we're now
aren't you the same can i add can i add
a few details though of this is my
childhood
no no no okay so
he hasn't seen her new like high self
maybe i'll like her now i have all
positive
relations with all my exes except for
this one because
the drive-by one because he's completely
blocked me out of his life
and that
he's your ex
that's hard for me
but
but it's like what what part of it is
hard okay i'll tell you so like i have
try to get to the bottom of this oh i
like this i
everyone in my life that i've shared
lovely times with like i can reach out
to them and and check up on them and
connect with them and remember the good
times and then here's this person who i
dated for
four years like three of my high school
years nothing to do with you yeah well
he knows how little you looked he's like
nervous about that
and
um
so it just bothers me that like all i'm
supposed to forget okay but why do you
need him
for your memory but wait what do you
mean you're not supposed to forget
really
you're just supposed to let go and
there's definitely a difference
oh
like you got like this beautiful ring
and you're happily engaged and david
it's not even wait till the vagina walks
in
let's see what day it's not even about
this guy it's about him
it's just your ego of like
you don't think so i think it's the
memories it's by the way memory but you
have the memories
can we make a clip of her eyes
fluttering when you said that her ego
she was like maybe it is my ego
it is my ego
it is you're totally right because it's
like
i'm like why can't we talk like why
i don't know
how many of your exes that haven't
blocked you
are you talking to on a regular basis on
a regular basis i don't talk about any
kind i don't talk to any exes on a
regular basis no and and when you do
talk to them what's what's the occasion
running into them at a comedy club
running into them yeah so like you're
not actively reaching out to any of them
no
unless kalila makes us colorado so
so there's literally actually no
difference between all of them and this
other one
only that like
that i can't actually you can't and
knowing you can is pissing you off yes
that's right
and it's such an old wound that like
this wound occurred when i was what like
the wound
that like being dumped
right yeah i don't know i wasn't there
so if if it is just oh you were there
oh my god it was him the whole time
um
i think like it's such a it's like a
childhood wound almost to me like the
first
like breakup and so oh that first one
sucks yeah yeah do you guys are well
mine uh is in prison or was in prison
[Music]
have you ever been like bullied about
like
hair loss i don't want to know
yeah me and jada
oh my god are you okay have you been
trying to trigger i mean a little bit
who are you i felt the slap a little bit
yeah you need betterhelp.com
we need better editing skills too carlos
but we also know i'm just kidding you're
being perfect
we all are going through stuff okay we
just watch the oscars and see a
traumatic event people are triggered all
over the place betterhelp will assess
your needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist and you
can connect in a safe and private online
environment it is so convenient and you
can start communicating with a therapist
in under 48 hours from night right now
when you you got an appointment coming
up it's not there yet you're feeling all
these feelings you want to remember them
you write it in the journal yes the
journal feature is very valuable for
that reason you don't have to worry
about running into an old friend an old
flame a ex-neighbor you had a fight with
in that office because betterhelp is all
online and it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available
carlos tell your parents they can get a
discount oh sweet carlos tell your
parents there's one thing they don't
need to pay for because you can actually
afford better help yourself
have you been bullied by a friend and
colleague about your financial situation
the fact that your parents are
supporting you fully
are you high at work
are you on drugs at work are you someone
who constantly interrupts and can't stop
talking and always brings it back to
themselves you need better help baby we
want you to start living a happier life
today as a listener you'll get 10 off
your first month by visiting our sponsor
at betterhelp.com
trash tuesday join over 1 million people
who have taken charge of their mental
health again that's better help
help.com
trash tuesday
[Music]
no but i did call him once i called him
i did the landmark forum when i was 19
and i was like you got to call like
everyone that you've had any sort of bad
blood with which is so disgusting it's
so bad
so weird so i called i remembered his
number he still lived in his parents
basement and i called him he's probably
on his water bed and uh
tommy hilfiger shirts that's our thing
he hung them like a wow oh yeah it's
crazy i lost my virginia on one
brag i don't wanna brag but i got
seasick what happened to you when he
lost virginia but um
he uh
i called him to be like hey like i feel
like i overreacted to our breakup we
were just kids we're like 14 he was 16.
i'm like you know i feel bad about that
he did [ __ ] my best friend afterwards um
i was like i'm so sorry for my part in
that and he was like oh i'm actually so
glad you called i always felt so bad
because i was never into i always really
liked
your friend hannah i was like oh they
just we're getting disconnected
but it backfired because i wasn't going
into it to actually a pilot there was
nothing i wanted to i wanted to get
something from him and he
did not he did not give me that but he
gave me a good story
did you freak out was that horrible i
thought it was funny honestly because it
was like so obvious i was trying to like
well i was just like seeking some sort
of like
you're the one that got away and he just
said the opposite he was like i actually
really only liked your friend i was like
okay
i got my my comeuppance pretty fast have
you do you have any exes that you're
like
you would drive by their house
no um
okay
but like
if i went home like to wisconsin yeah
and i was in the area
i might be like
i i could see myself maybe i've never
done it but like if i did it once it
would be like oh yeah like because it i
have nostalgic memories it's been so
long
and for the exes i do have even though
like when we were breaking up or times
there were like a lot of
like bad memories a moment like tears
but like i don't know how you feel but
like i have nothing but happy memories
now
oh okay so this is like like yeah don't
you like laugh about like
times that like
don't you laugh about like how
emotionally distraught you were like 10
years ago about things don't like don't
you go like wow i was
i was really upset then you know and
crying and
and all these things you don't look back
with a sense of
like perspective realizing that maybe
you gotta you got over it like you
no has not gotten over it i probably
you're actually blowing my mind because
i can tell you so clearly that i have
that
for all my other exes like even like
well do you think this is like a control
thing though like where it's like you
don't feel like you got like the last
say or whatever like he blocked you so
then you don't get yes but that's when
you need to just give it to yourself and
not because he's not gonna give it to
you right and then maybe he'll unblock
you once you don't give a [ __ ] anymore i
also think like the knife like cut so
deep and so hard but also i was so upset
when my first comedy
boyfriend broke up with me and i look
back at that like laughing like you said
like oh my god i was such a freak
but i don't have that for the high
school one like for some reason there's
something like unhealed there well you
haven't let go of the fact that he wants
he's blocked you
uh
well
maybe
next question
you feel out of like yeah you you you
don't have con you haven't gotten
control of that yeah i have no way of
contacting him and now what would you do
if you like are you expecting what would
you say something to you yeah are you
gonna say something to him no now
when you bring that up i'm like i have
nothing there's i don't want to see him
i don't want to say anything i think
maybe years ago i did for a while but i
definitely now i'm not i'm like
let's just we need to give you some
mushrooms and get like a pillow that
looks like him and you just say all
those things oh that i could be into my
my guesses okay is that yeah it
triggered you whatever and at some point
your ego told you it said something bad
about yourself
that he blocked you and you spent a lot
of time trying to figure out what does
this say about me that he did this the
thing is i know why he blocked me and it
was because i was really bored in acting
class um when i was here and i had just
moved to la when i quit school and i was
just texting him mean things about his
new girlfriend and that was when he
blocked sure
so i know why now i
but the fact that he still has you
blocked it's like i still feel like you
deep down see it as like uh
it's like a it's like a
it's something that's bad on your credit
score that you want to wait the seven
years for it goes away it's no longer on
your credit score it's like a ding
and i think it still like bothers you
that it's there and that the fact that
there's no entry
it's very annoying i but but just guess
what i'm talking about you blocking
someone else right and how it's like
you're blocking it for yourself it's not
about them it's like you're just going
this is not like i i'm at the point
where it's like if someone doesn't like
bring me joy and help my life i don't
owe them even an explanation it's just
like oh yeah move forward with love i
block you but you're not gonna even know
about the love because that's just a
vibration i'm sending to you
well you shouldn't be saying yeah like
blocking's for you not for them yeah and
if you're doing it for them you're doing
it for the wrong reasons yeah if you're
doing for them you're trying to control
right which he probably is not he just
his probably
girlfriend was like he was like yeah
like yeah they made me feel good about
my life and choices so i'm gonna cut you
off well this is actually blowing my
mind still like because you're right i
did have some like a friend breakup
recently and
i am not gonna text that person because
it's like what you said like you're not
it's it's negative and so i'm not gonna
text them and
that makes me see it from his position
right and his perspective and i'm like
oh yeah don't [ __ ] let me text you
like yeah i just learned that lesson too
where it's like the more i learn to set
my boundaries and sort of cut people out
that aren't working for me the more i
have grace for the people that did that
to me where my ego used to be like so
[ __ ] hit by it i'd be like you don't
want to talk to me or i go on a date
with a guy like why the [ __ ] would you
not want a second date with me
i'm like being [ __ ] insane
what about me also like blocking too is
like you know especially nowadays we
talk about dating and like toxic
behavior if you get blocked by someone
you're immediately thinking
am i
am i toxic yeah
like you're yes you're very it's it's
natural to feel defensive about
and that's why i would be so scared to
block people and i like i'm very
hesitant about it because
that's really severe but it was actually
annie that i learned from i watched her
block someone and so
casually blocked their phone number and
i was like oh my god i just was like i'm
done i just gave some chances i was like
i'm done it doesn't work
i just still admire that you did that
remember that in the future when i block
your [ __ ]
to see you
first
we just never
oh man if you do it the right way it's
just setting a boundary
okay it's just like yeah it's just like
i don't
this person reaching out to me or me
seeing their instagram and sometimes
blocking someone especially on social
media is for yourself because we lack
the willpower like you can mute someone
but that doesn't stop you from going to
their page and looking what's going on
but if you block someone you can't see
their [ __ ] either
at least on instagram yeah no i know i
think that's right so like if you're
like going through a breakup and like
you just keep like stalking their page
just block them and that way it's just
like for your mental health you're not
you're no longer
yeah
checking or like you're you know so much
about getting over someone is like
controlling your thoughts
also esther if you are like feeling
guilty when you're about to block
someone it's because
so you're now like
assuming that their experience of what's
gonna happen is gonna be like this crazy
negative thing but what if that person
sees their block from you feels all
those feelings gets through that feeling
of needing approval from other people
and you teach them one of their greatest
life lessons it's not really your
problem but whatever it was but i'm just
saying
right but you don't even i'm just saying
you have no clue like what is going on
in their heads it could be something
that like leads them to something even
better you know well she probably
doesn't do it because being blocked has
affected her so strongly right wait that
you're right that's why when you block
someone i was like that's so crazy do
you realize what you're about to do for
the next this next decade for the person
like yeah yeah they're going to be
driving by your house but
don't you feel like um
don't you feel like you learned from
that and became stronger because that
person blocked you you thought you were
never going to get over it and then
you're like no i have
and that person if it's who i think
we're talking about was kind of like not
being good to you too it's not like yeah
it's someone that was kind of like
controlling you and i think your success
probably wouldn't have landed on them
that well either i don't think it was
going to get easier the more successful
you got
with that one
[Laughter]
i got my girls back a little bit [ __ ]
you're jealous
you're jealous
um
wow i am definitely overwhelmed to be
discovering all this
nick you're
are you a therapist as well no
no
bachelor
he went through the weirdest dating i
definitely don't attribute anything i'm
doing whatever
though wild um
although i mean i guess i suppose it
like it just
it's a it was a crazy experience and to
get through that crazy experience i had
to be like introspective and
look at my own choices
but that was i learned that skill
from having to get over
relationships in my 20s i have a weird
thing to say that my i don't know if
it's but
because i watch well it's a weird one
because people watch our podcast and
they know stuff about us and then we
don't know anything about them and it's
weird but i always really liked your mom
your mom seems so cool my mom was great
yeah like you can tell like someone's
like gotten a good foundation your mom
always was she is she's the best uh i
mean she had 11 kids so i
but that alone that is that probably
gives you like advice selflessly because
you've seen so many different people's
stuff
uh i guess i don't know i mean i just i
had i had really good parents i had a
great childhood did you guys have two
minivans
we had all sorts of vehicle situations
we had like
like so we would go to like church at
the same time like very rarely yeah we'd
have to you have to take two cars to
church there was like a big van
situation for a period of time
it was weird yeah
that was the weirdest thing about having
a large family is like trying to go
places yeah that seems not possible or
like saving an entire pew
at church
you should take the family vance
uh but other than that is a relatively
normal where are you in the birth order
i'm the second oldest
therapist darlene is important your
birth order really apparently that's
yeah what do you what do you know about
the youngest it's not good huh
i don't know if either are good or bad
it's just
different impacts it does it does
there's some
and i know nothing about this like my my
therapist talks a little bit about it
but it it it's significant i guess
once you become 11 too that's like crazy
like so there's like an eight and nine
that are like it just kind of plays a
role in your childhood development i
understand it i don't know how but it
does well middle child is fun like my
boyfriend's a middle child i like middle
children because they were kind of
ignored so they learn like
self-sufficiency and like
how to take care of their girlfriends
and do other stuff for them
what are you
i'm i'm a twin i have an older brother
and a twin brother i'm in the middle but
yeah or no wait i'm the youngest i was
born after my brother but i was bigger
than him so i looked like the middle
yeah
do you like being a twin i love being a
twin
my brother doesn't hang out too much i
haven't talked to him in a while but
speaking of being blocked
oh wow so close
no i'm just i'm really close with his
wife and his kids oh that's great max is
uh he don't he's busy he's busy a lot
he's on twitter you know follow max
letterman
now you and carlos our producer have
something in common which is that you
both have controversial
body
talk you guys are both skinny men
i saw a post where you had to defend oh
that yeah defend being skinny that was a
weird day what happened
it was during
it was like it was during the pandemic
and the bachelor because of the pandemic
like
they couldn't film so they did this like
what can we put out like
when the pandemic first started a lot of
like even networks and stuff
were
like shoot like should we just play old
reruns and stuff and so
they did this um
like best of where they did like your
your top seasons so like
caitlyn's and ben's and mine and jojo's
were all picked and this was they were
like doing
a recap of caitlyn's season
and
i don't know like it was a pandemic so
like
i was working out and whatever it looks
i felt like i could like i posted that i
don't know what a caption
and like a lot of like midwest and i
think southern moms were telling me to
eat
you know like they didn't like you know
you're too skinny and i at
i've been fortunate enough in my life
where
like i haven't had to deal with a lot of
that stuff i worked out i've been active
i've been lucky enough to have a high
metabolism so like i'm pretty fortunate
where i haven't had to deal with a lot
of like
body dysmorphia and things like that and
i've been complicated does that mean
that you just like you you never diet is
that what you're saying i know i try to
eat healthy but like i was kind of
shocked how like it was just a lot of
comments it wasn't like like a couple
like five or ten being like
you should eat more it was just like a
lot and so the point where i felt my i
felt myself
like getting defensive and i felt myself
like uh wanting to respond like cazzy
david has this great line in her book
that i
that i i still remember and and and she
has this line
where any response to the internet is
insane regardless of what that response
is
and
it's true you never win a fight with the
internet but when i felt that urge to
want to defend myself to want to like
respond to every person and and and say
things like i ate
shake shack this morning or you know and
something and just the fact that i felt
like that was this kind of like
it was a wild thing so i put like
another post and it was just like i
don't know what this uh you know what i
don't know what i said but it was kind
of like oh now you're fat in this one
it was the next day i was it was like a
different angle and and uh
different camera and i don't know what i
said but i just kind of acknowledge that
like it bothered me yeah and words you
know it was just more like words matter
just be careful what you say because
like even the internet got to me and i
have no reason to like
go to bed worrying about like some
person on the internet telling me i look
too skinny like i know i'm healthy yeah
and even though i know i'm healthy it
still got to me
and and there are people out there who
do struggle with you know dieting and
eating and exercise and it's not as easy
for them to work out and their
metabolisms might not be as like
fast-moving as mine and like just be
careful with what you say i think was my
general i guess i feel opposite i feel
like everyone should say what they want
to say obviously within reason jaina i
love you g.i jane 2 can't wait to see it
all right
people are like as a comedian what do
you think i'm like what as a human i
think violence is always the loser you
don't get to use violence and also like
what really drives me crazy is i went to
look at jada pickett smith's um
instagram after all this happened like
three days before the oscars she did a
whole video about how she loves her bald
head anyone can make fun of it she
doesn't care comments are turned off so
what if rock had looked at that and gone
oh okay so this is okay to be made fun
of which by the way
obviously people's feelings get hurt and
stuff but i am a comedian i do i am on
the side of you can say whatever you
want we should get consequences but
nobody is allowed to put your hand their
hands on you no it's so disgusting it
makes me so mad i love what jim carrey
said he was like i would sue for 200
million i was like same like you can't
just hit a person for words in front of
everyone and he was doing it in such a
playful way it was not like it's not
okay and by the way the reason it's okay
to be made fun of or the reason we allow
the public is like cool with the oscars
in my opinion is like we're watching all
of these super rich people during a
pandemic incredibly wealthy incredibly
successful like disproportionate to the
rest of the world rich okay congratulate
each other give each other like
prizes for their time that they spent
like doing all this stuff the only way
it makes it equal is if they get made
fun of if not it's the most disgusting
thing i've ever seen and go jerk off in
the mirror
it's like you have to be made fun of or
there's no reason for this to exist i
saw him at the cellar a couple weeks ago
and i was blown away by his material i
was like where has he been we need him
to put out a special because his
material was like i just feel like what
the world needed to hear and the ticket
sales have gone through the roof because
everybody wants to support him and see
him and he's gonna make so much good
that's cool the whole set is gonna be
amazing that makes me happy it's like
you just can't be violent you just can't
be violent yeah i i i
have always felt like i can say whatever
i want especially in a performance yes
and not expect someone to lash out and
hit i've had someone come on stage and
they had a security took forever i was
like hello
i did it it was halloween and this guy
was heckling and i went oh my god it's
so weird that you're here being so loud
because i was going to go as your mom
for halloween but i couldn't fit that
many dicks in my mouth standard mom joke
okay
basic as they come cute people laughed
the guy stood up he's like how dare you
talk about my mother and i went oh my
god i didn't realize she was such a
[ __ ] that you thought i would know her
and then he charged them out i thought
all the security was there they went
there was like security security
security but someone grabbed him right
as he was about to punch me on stage but
i'm like punch me punch me i'll get a
netflix special
[Music]
i love athletic greens they're so i wake
up every morning and i have them i'm not
kidding you i'm so excited i wake up i
have my cup that they sent me i shake it
i use the individual packages i have the
um
i have the container too but the
individual packages are always like all
over my house because i just whenever i
remember to take them i just take them i
shake them up that's how i break my fast
i've been on my peloton i got my little
greens there it makes me feel so good so
energized so healthy so what is this
stuff wait a second well you did you
know with one delicious scoop of
athletic greens you're absorbing 75 high
quality vitamins minerals whole food
source superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day
right this special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health yes your
nervous system your immune system your
energy recovery focus and aging all the
things we absolutely love athletic
greens and right now we think it's time
to reclaim your health and arm your
immune system with convenient daily
nutrition especially heading into cold
and flu season which is literally all
the time now honestly you know how many
kalila is eating right now she's like
chugging athletic greens oh for sure i
facetimed her on the way over and she is
still drinking athletic greens and still
working out she's crazy it costs you
less than three dollars a day you're
investing in your health and it's
cheaper than a cold brew habit you know
it's just one scoop in a cup of water
every day that's it no need for a
million different pills and supplements
to look out for your health and to make
it easy athletic greens is going to give
you a free one year supply of immune
supporting vitamin d and five free
travel packs with your first purchase i
have to say that vitamin d dropper i
take it with me everywhere i go it's my
favorite thing that it's so good all you
have to do is visit athleticgreens.com
tuesday again that is athleticgreens.com
tuesday to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
i'm really worried
about the internet the internet's gonna
ruin the world what's going on with you
in the internet it's getting good it's
gonna be what did you see in the dark
web that we don't know about
no but don't like you don't have the
dark web but if you want to go to you
know you've ever seen like the matrix or
terminator
yeah and those movies seen either of
those
it's so cute that you lied she loves you
that was cute no it's because i'm a
little high and i was like i know those
words you wanted to fit in both those
movies and there's other movies are
basically about like machines taking
over the world like artificial
intelligence like in in both movies it's
like different how they do it but it's
essentially
artificial intelligence is born and it
basically advances on its own and it
takes over the world it's taking over
and i feel like it's already it's
happening
well then why is carlos it's just it's
just
it's just a robot can do it but it's not
a robot it's just it's it's our phones
and the machine is an algorithm that is
brainwashing humans into thinking how it
it wants to think like we're not
thinking for ourselves anymore more
we're being
we're being radicalized
by our phones and how much time like our
screen time my instagram ads because i
do like the outfits i mean no it's just
it's everything i'm trying to cover my
nipples with my hair doesn't it scare
you when you go and i use it as much as
anyone like so like don't if you're
aware of that don't you feel like okay i
can consume the content and i try i'm
the opposite i think it's smarter than
that
let's do it he's naughty he knows what
i'm saying take over
i don't know i i that that's my i'm not
a conspiracy theorist but that's my
that's my fear if i have a fear it's
that uh
the the technology is
is too advanced for our so
upgrade i think that's the difference
between being like a tall man and like a
small girl
how so
cuz like i'm just more afraid of like
the things like right in front of me
not being able to grab the cereal
she's in fight or flight
open the jar like you you have to like
get a little more creative about it i
like how even the jar is so big when you
did the panel
that was literally me today i have to
get more creative about the things i
worry about yeah like you have to i
think that's a normal concern like
you're not crazy or anything i just feel
like when i i've like thought about a
lot i'm like i think that that if if
humans have created this or if you want
to thank god or whatever is like
creating all this they created our
ability to create this
new technology so isn't this the way
maybe we're supposed to be evolving and
that i believe in our species will catch
up
and we'll but maybe or we'll die
i hope you're right i'm just we're the
computers
do you have no you don't have kids no
i'm sorry nothing's about you what i
just it's weird to just tell people you
know things about them oh well okay so
my take on what you just said is i
forgot because i'm high what'd you say
i said that if we were like we were
created to have the ability to create
this technology okay i
believe what both of you are saying like
i believe that the internet and like
social media and all the technology
we're exposed to like
we're not evolved our little like animal
bodies and minds are not evolved to
handle it and that is my argument to
myself as to why i started taking
lexapro because i had really bad anxiety
and i was like oh like i'm not
supposed to like see thousands of
comments and and like do a stand-up show
for people every five nights a week
whatever like
i i'm just like we're i'm not ready so
i'm gonna like take the man-made
medication to help me cope with this
does that feel like in alignment with i
think what you're saying yeah saying
hello
yeah i guess yeah she's a lexapro
they are paying her to do that i wish
five milligrams that's all i need um
yeah
i yeah uh i think just what's supposed
to happen is happening and we're all
gonna be fine you're uh everything
happens for a reason person i have to be
what else
i've been [ __ ] molested so much
i've got to be that is my coping
mechanism no but i do feel like i feel
like things have worked out so i do
think that if i'm going off the evidence
of my own life that
they've always worked every time i've
been like so upset about something
it's
shifted and become a good thing in the
end i'll say i relate to that too it's
like i trust that it's like you're
supposed to be where you are where
you're supposed to be kind of thing
i was trying to make a right answer i
was supposed to be born in the same
timeline as skims like that i know yeah
and
i just threw out a pair of skins
why it just was worn i was like i've
i've worn this to its end it felt hard
it's a quality product is it not we're
lovely we love does your girlfriend love
skims yeah what does your girlfriend do
she's a surgical technologist
yeah okay that's cool
uh
yeah it's a it's a quality product we
love good on the kardashians
yeah why do they have to create
something so good
you can't you like it's like
everybody wants to hate on them and it's
like they just keep they work producing
the best [ __ ] i can't i know i even
remember when i got i was like oh i got
my first pair of jeans since i gained
weight in the pandemic and you're like
you know what jeans those are it was the
khloe kardashian ones oh yeah brand i
can't help but accidentally i just buy
kardashians well they have like we talk
about them the most so they have the
most like organic advertising of any
company they're like the new they're
like as big as amazon are they i don't
know not in amazon not quite as big but
like nordstrom no they're they're it's
they're all billionaires you keep
thinking we have like a lot of like
answers you're looking at us like we're
gonna have these very specific answers
and it's so funny you're like right
don't they make
mama daddy what's your what's your
tattoo say
oh on your arm funny you should ask
this one says sleepover now bye because
when i was in elementary school me and
my childhood best friend would always
say come over now bye and then hang up
and this one says kalila which is the
name of the woman who usually sits in
that chair
and she hasn't been back since she saw
the tattoo
and then sunset boulevard is one of my
favorite movies
one of the only movies i've ever seen
i've never even seen it
what is that movie
what sunset boulevard norma desmond she
walks down the staircase i'm ready for
my close-up mr dominic okay yeah that's
sick crazy old lady
that your aspirations yes are you
kidding me yes okay yeah how was the joe
rogan returned to the comedy it was
really fun it was cool was he well
received he was yeah it was well it was
funny because in one room tony said that
he had 20 inch cliff who's tony was
there you saw yeah it was so fun it was
so funny the boys were back in town baby
and and we're close
he was the one oh no he wasn't the one
we facetimed no that was right but he
was close a family member oh my god you
saw him what was it it was really fun
funny was tony weird he was great they
were so fun but they it was it was
interesting to see them come back
because i think maybe a part of them
would have wanted
everyone to be like not thriving without
them like maybe their egos would have
enjoyed that they didn't say that but
you know but they kept being like well
is it like this packed usually i'm like
yeah i mean but i do believe rogan
coming back to the comedy store made it
that popular yeah i agree but it is a
different vibe now it's really cool but
so they were in the main room and then
tony said that he went into the or and
the comic before him was just trashing
rogan
and then like but killing
and then and then was like the next
comic is tony
[Laughter]
so to do like that both experiences but
it was good it was fun it was fun to
have them back everyone's excited are
friends with benefits worth it depends
on your expectations
i think friends with benefits are are
totally reasonable like
type of relationship to have for a
period of time in your life but they
have an expiration date for sure
sorry
we're closed
[Laughter]
it's it doesn't usually last long and
like
it really requires like two mature
people to set up front expectations
and usually listen here's the thing when
when you're out there dating and you're
trying to like meet someone and dating
is hard enough and what is like
you're trying to meet someone it's like
i wanna if you try to oversimplify what
you're looking for generally people are
like i want someone who like
i enjoy like talking to
and i have good sex with like i want a
physical connection and i want them like
i want to hang out and a friends with
benefits
you know do you just have sex usually
someone
if you can't stand them
eventually the sex won't be worth it
wait right now and if you can stand them
one of the one of those two people now
you want to [ __ ] your friends no no now
i want to have sex with someone who
can't stand me
uh dave [ __ ] dave tonight
[ __ ] your husband right now so
empowering like you can't stand me but
you still want to have sex
those relationships that's 20s [ __ ] i
can't imagine doing that in my 30s like
that's what i'm saying eventually
eventually like if you if they if you if
you are not annoyed by them one of the
two people are like well i guess i like
you because yeah we have good sex you
don't annoy me i've met
some of your friends we make each other
laugh like what the [ __ ] yeah and then
you know and so it just
it's a very temporary thing but sure why
not i always feel like when i was like
out on the prowl and i was like
uh i always thought like every time i
have sex with someone it's like i either
like love them or hate them afterwards
there's always like a strong emotion and
maybe that was my own [ __ ] back then
but
um hopefully i'm never love or hate them
like i just had like a strong feeling
afterwards it was never just like we're
cool regardless of like and that was
like regardless of like their behavior
like the ones you hated was there like a
reason or you just wouldn't be
necessarily them it would be like my
like how i made myself feel would just
make me like grossed out by them kind of
like oh okay like me why did i do this a
situation where you may be hooked up but
then you were like did i even really
want to why yeah there were so many
others what was i trying to prove what
was i yeah yeah
but
it never i mean i had like a friend with
benefits for a while but then i just got
so like
i've never had that but i'm now inspired
to take what you said about friends with
benefits which is you just described it
as like someone that you like talking to
and that you like having sex with and
well usually it's it starts because you
hook up
and then there's a conversation around
like hey i'm not really looking for
anything serious you're like me too and
you're like
i guess we like and then you don't
really talk about it at first there's
usually like
like a you up text at some point and
like that second time you have you hook
up there's this like
hey like maybe we should keep doing this
or some version of that it's a very
temporary thing most toxic to me oh they
most they often turn in toxic what they
turn into is some sort of like situation
ship which is like when one person wants
to date and the other person's like
i thought it was when you date the guy
from the jersey shore
did he make that up because wasn't his
name like the situation it might be him
it was them i think that made it up so
many of the things that i'm going to say
is like a jersey shore wait what i i
don't think so no but i would almost
believe that it was it was the situation
right yeah it was mike this morning but
situationship sounds like so general too
yeah i think it's a very pop it's like
it's the thing it's just a good joke
oh no it's the thing i had a friend that
um i had gone to my quaker youth
retreats with when i was
like you know we're quicker
you can't just casually
drop that yes
but they took me we had this thing
called youthquake so we went to these
like these these things they were like
all the different queens you're being
serious is that why you're funny because
when you grew up you went to something
called youth i know isn't that wild well
i almost got kicked out so i was like a
juvenile delinquent but also in this
like church group
so they sent us it was all the different
like quaker youth groups
i'm very ignorant when it comes to the
quick quickerism because it's not it's
not
amish and i'm assuming a lot of people
confuse the two yeah i would always be
like we turned better on fridays it was
like my quaker joke those had bits guys
i always had bits
they molested me young they got me funny
quick quick quick quick ah sorry nikki
stark
the bell the bell it's really not dark
from your set to my set last night they
went through a lot the audience went
through a lot i know that was the truth
the true trifecta me then you then
whitney
that was a lot of female comedy for the
crowd a lot of just telling the truth
about some things yeah but um
so quakerism is a it's a form of
christianity that's like pretty hippie
[ __ ] it's like very very close to like
unitarianism or something but it's
so you sit in silence and these they
call them face inventions i know that's
why i talk so much
but you're gonna love i can't wait to
tell you more you're gonna love this
okay
so you sit in silence they ruined you
they tortured you wait or did i torture
them just wait so you do have an
opportunity to talk if you feel like god
so you're supposed to sit in silence and
you you've got speaking to you you raise
your hand well if god speaks through you
right and so like so they called them
the quakers because people used to shake
in the beginning when they did it but
it's like then it got like really chill
so it was just like
quakers are like you could be gay you
can be anything you want like the whole
thing was that god's in the form of an
inner light that's in everyone and
everything so there's goodness in
everyone so they're pacifists
like you didn't have to go i know but
then i met you [ __ ]
i was like there's evil in there satan's
in her
no but um so so there were jewish people
in quaker meeting it was totally weird
it was like anyone that wants to come
you're in
um
so you say you sit like facing each
other and then you if you feel moved to
speak you stand up and speak you can say
anything you want okay so people and it
wasn't you it was god
well that kind of got that can get
tricky that got a little bit
in the back and it used to be god
speaking through but it was more like if
you're just mine
by the way it's god speaking
god here you look like [ __ ] in yellow
pants esther
better not get your period
i'm just a vessel i actually had like my
one of my like
people that i follow my i don't want to
call him a guru because that's not
really what it is but
he has a a shaman and he was saying like
that this shaman once said another
shaman was channeling through him to
tell him that he had a big ego and i was
like that's so funny to be like it's
actually another guy chain i'm going to
tell you that
you are cocky
but anyway so what did they do so i
would stand up every meeting you know i
would have every meeting my brother was
like my twin was like you said what i
was saying he was like but you were good
i would like i would just get something
whereas like i knew i was gonna like
get all the attention i stand up and be
like sometimes i just think of the kids
in somalia like i just would catch one
thing and just like oh and i just
i wish i could share my food with them
you know like just like such
just like i was like the the og virtue
signaler
and i would stand up but i also would
stand up and say my brother reminded me
that once i stood up and i was like do
you ever like
like think about how weird it would be
if you weren't you that you're in your
body and like you have your teachers and
your siblings and your parents and that
you could have just been born another
person and max was like people would
clap
but i was just like this is why i do
stand up oh yeah this is your origin
story like everyone had to be quiet and
then one person could go stand in front
of everyone no you just stand up where
you are oh and nobody really looks at
you everyone stays looking down it's
very cool it's like they'll have like a
fire in the winter i was in philadelphia
and there you'd hear like the fire pop
it was really beautiful sometimes i go
back when i'm home if i'm there on a
sunday i'll go back to quaker meeting
but um
anyway so they had these quaker youth
groups
and there's also so that's unprogrammed
quakerism then there's program quakers
and that's like they go read from the
bible they have a pastor it's like the
kids when we went to youthquake all the
program kids were like homophobic we
were like what the hell we're all like
we were like the first non-binaries i
would like to say everyone was [ __ ]
half shaved head it was like we were the
ogs
of little of the weirdos
um but so we went to accepted everybody
we accepted everyone yeah that was it
was about acceptance and then so we went
on this youth retreat i was like 14. and
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
no i love finding out one of my best
friends grew up being taught to accept
everybody now i feel very not special i
mean it took a while
we've had some off times
i had to go back to church a couple
times
no but uh so we went on this thing and
uh this girl emily and i were in the
same room it was like a dorm room i
guess we were all staying in this giant
like you know four
ten-story dorm room we were all staying
in these dorm rooms
and they had overheard we were smoking
cigarettes and stuff but i think they
let us smoke cigarettes i don't know if
we had to sneak and smoke cigarettes but
um
we had told they called the adult
friendly presences that watched us fps
that is crazy they didn't molest us
those were the ones that didn't really
yeah shocking friendly presents
fingering presents fp
fingering people people to finger
um but so they had heard me and this
girl emily say we were gonna sneak out
to go like hang out with these guys
and so they um
they sat outside our dorm room so we
tied the the sheets together and climbed
out
and scaled the wall in winter and
climbed into and i just got my nipples
pierced i remember annie and we climbed
into those kids this guy was friend that
i had just met and we like made out or
whatever they played with our boobs and
then we went back and we didn't get
caught and we weren't kicked out and it
was really fun but years later
i reconnected with that guy whose room i
climbed into
just randomly he just like hit me i was
like crazy if we're about to find out
that he died in like a plane crash or
something that happens sometimes on here
when we talk about a guy hooked up with
we look good and he died yeah we have to
mourn him final destination they're like
you should have died from this [ __ ] she
doesn't know what final destination is
but she i do know it but i i need to
rewatch it i saw the first one and i was
like this is not for me oh my god i love
it it's like my favorite well you know
someone's gonna die but you don't know
how they always tease you like they'll
be marbles like about to fall on their
head or something and then it's always
like a different do i have to look at
them no okay no
carlos you can't advertise that you
don't eat on our show we just talked
about we don't have any decisions
because
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
are we in a workplace
and like guys with shirts come
a man concerned with personal appearance
who places more emphasis on having a fit
toned viral body than on
a hundred percent
no grooming
oh my god spornosexual
appearance but who places no emphasis on
having a fit toned viral it's like
skinny i think it's just about being
skinny or something you've never heard
of this nick i feel like you not okay
why would i know about this because
you're like a guy in the media i don't
know
so are you [ __ ]
the same guy coined the term metro
section oh okay we're just like that's
the same guy so this is just his like
second yeah his big what if it is i hate
this guy yeah i know so no you don't get
the queen well growing up in the midwest
back in the day i was
everyone called me metrosexual and i
took offense to it because it was like
why do we need a name for someone who
just like likes stripes yeah
or like flashes their armpits you know
because like i didn't want to like i i
you know i i guess i cared about
i liked fashion to a certain degree now
i wonder if it's like like gross women
like me that liked that term because i
d i actually would prefer a man that
doesn't wash his body like i i would
rather like a big well we know why
why because it makes you not as
obviously smelly yes thank you thank you
it's less pressure
it does take right it's like you know
you don't want someone i dated a guy
once who was like i have the best smell
i was like goodbye i can't i'm like
no
he's like i have a super small i'm like
no no no no no we're done dude it's like
when i first pressure when dave and i
like he could smell yeah he's like i
have the best smell i'm like goodbye oh
not like i smell the best no he was like
i can smell really like he's like i
could smell anything i get and you were
just like you know what i don't know
i get that that would be i was like i
also don't like when a guy eats less
than me i've gotten over this though now
but sorry carlos you're out when me and
dave first started dating he he went to
get a subway brag um and he came back
and i had ordered a foot long and he
came back and he only got himself a
six-inch and i was like i felt like i
had been slapped in the face like i was
so betrayed
i would actually love to slap you in the
face with a sandwich can we do that on
the live
that's so sad is that society who does
that to it that does it that's a good
that's a good healthy person's reaction
um that it is weird yeah i think it's
like as a girl i think i don't think
you're the only one i don't think it's
girly can i tell you i don't think it's
girly i think it's codependent i have
the same thing i'm like i thought we
were doing the same thing if we're both
i do this with kalyala too i'm like if
we're gonna like i thought we were both
gonna eat the same amount are we gonna
need a lot or a little well i didn't get
that impression from her though yeah i
know what you're saying but i feel like
for me it's more it was more
you're the guy
and i'm you're like supposed to be your
small girlfriend and i'm eating double
but now i double than what he does i
don't care i'm not i'm like more
confident now he does carry his weight
differently than you what are you
calling i'm not saying he's i'm saying
you are much much skinnier than this
what are you saying we dave listen
you're very handsome i love you you're a
wonderful man when you compliment me i
remember it
forever one time and we were on a hill
and i said a thing about an elephant and
you laughed
and i'll never forget it
um no you're right i'm
i weigh less than him does cooking make
you a pikmi girl does it
i like to cook i'm the i'm the cooker in
our household we okay i think that girls
who are always posting about i've made
this meal look at my pasta i think
that's pick me girl vibes because
they're like really
maybe i'm again just insecure hater
jealous and hater but i feel like this
is people being like i know content
yeah
my friend does our whole thing i know
how to cook muffins i guess i'll do that
my friends are forager my best friend
from college is a forager tara elena
gabriele the medic medicine circle
follower but sure her whole career is
like making beautifully colored foods
from her husband has a garden and they
like
so she gets all the ingredients fresh
from there and forages them from like
the woods and stuff and puts them all
together i get that there's people like
that and that's not what i'm just saying
but you're saying i'm such a good catch
look i can cook i can clean i can do
this stuff hey just for me
i view that as pikmi vibes you know i'm
not going to be if i was single i
wouldn't be going out there like look at
my fresh pasta i made like nobody
expected that
maybe the fresh pasta
it's an interesting question i thought i
was thinking the other day too though
but like i i it came out of your body if
it was the [ __ ] maybe look at the pasta
i made me
annie no
[Music]
that's what i'm comfortable about like i
do most of the cooking
with between natalie and i i love that i
like i i'm a good little housewife
someday i like
helpful boys that's all we want but i
it's
and i've never thought of myself as a
typical guy and i don't know if that i'm
not saying that's good or bad i'm saying
but i would find it to be weird
metrosexual
uh
i just couldn't like it'd be
uncomfortable for me to like
do guys like do you have you noticed
dating
like knowing guys and dating guys that
they there are guys who are looking for
women to like make them food on the
regular i have seen it on like make them
a sandwich or like
we just i i need to participate
like i i couldn't imagine just sitting
there and being like i guess serve me
dinner like it'd be like once in a while
like nelly wants to do something nice
but like
we it's not either of our jobs like the
idea that a guy would be looking for a
girl to like i need someone
to cook like you know and so you're
saying because like you're saying is
cooking a pick me girl vibe
it there would need to be men and maybe
there are i'm asking who are actually
looking for like oh
muffins
i guess i'm just i've never been that
guy there's a guy because i've always i
guess like to cook and act of service is
my love language like i like to do
things that's how i show love what's
yours getting gifts
[ __ ] you
not watching tv sitting in a room
staring at a ceiling
watching the news
oh i like i like them all what i'm
receiving
um
receiving is my lovely that's no but i
was thinking
how do you like the show love oh um what
are the choices
of service uh
words affirmations of affirmation
quality time
touch
i like touch
quality time it's so cute for me with
their little hands too touch
so precious little nails oh
but you made me think of this as a
tangent but i think it's worth going
down but i am still slightly high you'll
let me know there was this like famous
serial killer no no not a serial killer
this guy who killed his his wife and i
think he killed his sons yes it's
actually very tragic it's not funny but
he had all these journals saved love he
recorded all this audio of himself
before he killed everybody and including
himself and one of the things he said
that was so creepy was he was like
oh when i first met her and i saw the
way she cleaned the bathroom i knew she
was the one
so it's like
guys like are looking for that and no
judgment like not just all of them will
kill people their wives
but not all anyone who like asks their
girlfriend to make him a sandwich not
guaranteed to be a murderer it's not
always but that's a good starting point
but it could it is like a controlling
thing i guess because you're right it's
like there's no autonomy in that if it's
like my i have to do this and then you
have to do this i mean we're like you
know 50 years ago that was a thing yeah
you know and it was more traditional but
i'm just now realizing that no one will
ever be able to give me the acts of
service that i need satiate your just
desire to be taken as good as one person
that is my mom
because she is fully so make it let's
call her ask her
when carlos came to my house i was like
so just so you know when my when we're
at with my mom like she handles
everything do you should write a joke
about that
like but because but she handles
everything like she
it's a control thing for her mom like i
couldn't throw away a water
like i couldn't throw away anything out
like esther was like leave it on the
counter she'll throw it away yeah
special trash can where she wants it
like but yeah yeah no because i
understand that too because i feel like
sometimes i don't want to like
generalize but in the asian my
boyfriend's asian and his mom is like so
like she loves to like where are we
going do i should i know she like loves
to she's a terrible driver but no no
no but she he's writing down edit out
no he's like make it the clip are you
kidding me nick we're trying to go viral
nick viral is what we call you
um
but and we call kalila nick viral load
because she does have kovid um but she
is asian but she is asian but but it is
like in her culture and her it's like a
joy for her to like
serve you and cook for you and stuff
like that and it seems like your mother
like
that's her thing that's her thing yeah i
have a question for you have you blocked
a lot of people's phone numbers like is
it so easy and casual for you or is it a
big deal it gets easier now because i
just know it's for me like now that i
know it's for me and it's not like in a
manipulative way you don't feel this
like sense of like fear that like what
if they need to call me or there's
nothing they could need to call me even
my
my ex-boyfriend that i see at the comedy
store all the time he when he approaches
i see him and i go
like i'm always like i give him nothing
because there's nothing he can bring my
life anymore we're done
he we had a we had a tumultuous
relationship some of it was bad some of
it was beautiful i thank him for the
good parts and the lessons i learned
from the bad parts but i there is i do
not operate on the same vibrational
level as him anymore i have nothing to
say to him he comes up i am just like
the finality of that is so
it's blowing my mind like i want i it
just why is it such a big deal to me
like you should block that ex back
block him
honestly maybe yeah just block them for
your own energy
it's your choice interesting
when night book comes out can you read
it and tell anything absolutely yeah and
please come back and give we need him
and kalila in the same room i'm a little
nervous about it i think it's good how
about the book well i'm not a writer
at all who cares and you wrote it
yourself yeah good well because i do the
i i do the questions with nick on my
instagram you saw and then i went to a
publisher and i was like i don't really
want to write a book because i'm not a
writer but i have i do this series every
sunday this q a and i have thousands of
them and like
i think they can make like a fun coffee
table book like let's just like
repackage them you guys make it look
nice yeah and they're like yeah great
and then they gave me a book deal and
they were like but no we want you to
write a book and i was like
okay but like
this is on you because i don't know
where commas go
and
so i was like i don't know if i was like
i don't think i can do this this is like
two years ago but i i slowly sleep i'm
glad you didn't ask me to read it
because i i'm not able to read it so i'm
so glad that you said that but what do
you do not let the advice
know i wrote it in like sections
and then it was like putting a puzzle
together and like i just wrote thoughts
right i just had an idea of a thing i
wanted to that's how you do it yeah i
guess it turns out and and then they put
and then and then
what the [ __ ] would you know the [ __ ]
but that's what i've been told and then
i put it together and like obviously the
editor and like helped you know we had
it and then we kind of grammar
they put the commas in the right spot
for sure
um
and then i read it and i felt like it's
pretty good because like i actually
meant a lot when you said you liked my
tick tock because
sometimes
i'm worried that like
it's like it's once like i'll go on the
street and people like
i love your podcast or i love your tick
tock and i'm like really because like
sometimes i'm self-conscious about like
being the guy who's just like well this
[ __ ] guy again telling me what to do
like who am i
your people type of thing yeah your
people are your people how awesome is it
that even though you're self-conscious
about that you still [ __ ] are true to
yourself and you put it out there my
whole thing these last few months is
like
i don't care what anybody thinks of me i
don't care what i post like if that's
what i want i see we noticed we did
notice about two months ago no
that is the way to go not giving a [ __ ]
but when i get in my head it's just like
would i like me if i wasn't me you ever
wonder about that
but like no that's none of your business
either though okay well yeah thankfully
and as you know my mom really loves me
and she gave me incredible confidence
and i owe a lot of my success to my mom
because i'm like
i have this perfect combination of like
self-doubt but like i don't know i think
i can do it i i'd call me crazy it was
kinda like right in the book it's like
maybe i can my mom believes in me the
fact that you finish the book it's
getting published i promise you it's
good
i've had a few people uh read it and i i
think it's pretty decent but um
no and i i genuinely mean that like i
see your tick tocks pop up on my feed
and i always watch them and always feel
like i learned something and
you give good advice and i i'm like i
think i'm a good advice giver so i feel
qualified to say that like it's really
good don't i don't know
well you you can read it and tell me
what you think you can read it too
um actually
my ego has managed to this episode okay
we get it you guys love each other
you can read um but um nick thank you
for being here oh you guys are great
thank you that was so fun to have yeah
everybody thank you for listening and
please subscribe to this channel or i'll
get more spankings and i don't want them
actually there is a post i will be
making last night you spanked me so hard
it felt good
congrats esther i know what you need
if you think i don't know what you need
i was like spanker i was like your her
ass is chris rock oh my gosh
i have footage of it i'll post it but
please do all right to the podcast we'll
see you guys next week bye thanks guys
get the book
not out yet get the book in october
[Music]
you